[موسيقى]
منذ القدم واهالينا قال لهم العرب على
درايه تامه واهتمام واسع بعلم فلك وكانوا
يسمونه بعلم الحياه بين قوسين علم الهيئه
لارتباطه الوثيق بحياتهم المعاشيه
والمعاديه ويتفاخرون فيما بينهم بمدى
معرفتهم باحوال هذا العلم وفروعه فهم سكان
صحراء جافه وقاحله وذات حراره عاليه واهل
تنقل وترحل فمن لا يعرف خفاياها يدركه
الموت ولو كان ذا بسطه في الجسم والنجوم
هي الحركه الواصله بينهم وبين الحياه رب
ليل كانه الدهر طولا قد تناها فليس فيه
مزيد ذي نجوم كانهن نجوم الشيب ليس تزول
لكن تزيد
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
والبلدان العربيه هي القنطره الواصله بين
اسيا وافريقيا ونقاط انطلاقها اليمن الشام
العراق ومرتكزها الحجال فاذا ارادوا
الذهاب الى العراق مشوا على نجم سماك واذا
ارادوا اليمن مشوا على نجم سهيل واذا
ارادوا الشام مشوا على نجوم الثريا اي
منكح الثريا سهيلا عمرك الله كيف يلتقيان
هي شاميه اذا ما اطلت وسهيل اذا اطل
يماني
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]